alors le bilan quand même de cette
ouverture la concurrence j'y tiens parce
que en quelques mots parce que il y a
quand même beaucoup de choses fausses
qui ont été dites le bilan est
globalement positif pour les voyageurs
c'est vrai que à chaque ouverture à la
concurrence quand on change de
délégataire de service public et vous
connaissez ça dans vos territoires
puisque tous les territoires de France
sont en délégation de service public il
n'y a plus aujourd'hui que la RATP qui
est en monopole sur Paris tous les
territoires sont Délégation de Service
publi quand on change le délégataire
d'une délégation de transport il y a
toujours une petite période un peu
compliquée de transition à gérer le
sortant ne laissant pas forcément les
matériels en meilleur état
emportant parfois avec lui un certain
nombre de salariés pour les emmener sur
un autre territoire et cetera donc c'est
ce qui s'est passé évidemment quand on a
ouvert les premiers lots enfin plus
exactement à chaque fois qu'on ouvre un
lot et que la tributaire n'est pas le
sortant il y a des petites friction de
démarrage voilà c'est encore le cas à
cette rentrée sur le lot de Versailles
euh qui est passé de Keolis à Transdev
c'est aussi enfin c'est voilà c'est le
cas à chaque fois voilà alors mais si on
regarde sur la durée c'est-à-dire les
lots qui ont été ouverts il y a 2 ans
par exemple on voit clairement une
amélioration du service parce que dans
le cadre de de l'ouverture à la
concurrence dans le cadre de la
délégation de service public on a
demandé plus de service une meilleure
qualité et on voit aussi des nouvelles
offres de servicees par les concurrents
en LCE